we are now learning that Fox News had
the stormy Daniels illegal hush money
payments long before anybody else and
they decided in order allegedly to help
Donald Trump to kill the story and to
say nothing about it this is yet another
bombshell revelation from the New
Yorkers Jane Mayer in this very good
piece that was published yesterday Fox
News used to have a reporter named Diana
Falzone maybe she pronounces it Falzone
e I'm not sure and Diana knew about the
stormy Daniels illegal payments she had
proof of the affair with Donald Trump
she confirmed the entire story with
multiple sources including stormy
Daniels herself before Donald Trump was
elected the timing of this is really
important this was before the 2016
election Falzone did great investigative
work she found emails between trumps
then attorney Michael Cohen and the
lawyer that was representing stormy
Daniels related to the money related to
the non-disclosure agreement everything
but Fox News never ran the story as I'm
sure you know by now we learned about
this much later and not because of Fox
News is reporting Fox News executive Ken
LaCorte reportedly went to the reporter
Diana Falzone who did her job she
actually did her job and told her let
the story go
the reported quote is good reporting
kiddo but Rupert meaning Rupert Murdock
wants Donald Trump to win so just let it
go so let's be really clear here to
everyone who says that the entire thing
is false news Fox News has admitted that
they had the story okay they have a
different explanation for why they
didn't run it the former editor-in-chief
of Fox News digital told CNN last year
this is not even news at this point that
yes Fox News had the story but they
opted not to publish it because they
felt that some of the facts had not been
verified okay so they've already
admitted they had the story they said
it's a credibility issue that kept them
from publishing it Jane Mayer now is not
the first to say Fox News had the stone
she is the first to say that it was a
political decision that was made because
Rupert Murdoch
wanted Donald Trump to win another sign
that this is almost certainly true is
that Fox News paid off the reporter in
question Diana Falzone
including not only giving her money but
forcing her to sign a nondisclosure
agreement where she cannot talk about
the circumstances under which Fox News
refused to go with the stormy Daniels
case and that it would specifically
prevent her from explaining that for
example it was a political decision that
was made because they didn't want to
hurt Donald Trump so what we've learned
in the last 24 hours is that number one
Fox News proactively covered up
reporting on crimes committed by then
presidential candidate eventual
president-elect eventual president
Donald Trump
they hid relevant information from
voters this sounds to me like Rupert
Murdoch needs to be subpoenaed by any
number of House committees at this point
and I wouldn't be surprised if Sean
Hannity is also pulled into this or
involved in some way consider that Sean
Hannity is regularly speaking to
President Donald Trump privately Sean
Hannity was once listed as one of only
three clients of indicted Trump personal
attorney Michael Cohen something which
has been denied by Hannity but if indeed
Hannity's denial is true in other words
if it's true that Cohen never
represented Hannity or worked for
Hannity there is no attorney-client
privilege that can be cited with regards
to what Hannah need Hannity knew about
this and so many other Fox related
Fiasco's let's get Sean Hannity in front
of the committee as well given that
attorney-client privilege is simply not
going to be an issue so this exposes
much of what we already suspected but
what it's giving us is particular
instances where the facts now say this
is the propaganda arm of the Trump
administration and they may now have
been involved in the cover
in the preventing of the breaking of
news that the president was involved in
criminality criminality that is not
hypothetical criminality in those
illegal hush money payments for which
people have now been convicted and are
going to prison let me know what you
think about all of this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman follow me there and follow
the show at david pakman show on twitter
as well one of the day's sponsors is
privacy comm slash Pakman which is a
free service that I myself use really
useful in many different ways takes just
a few seconds to link your debit card to
privacy calm then you can create virtual
credit cards that are linked directly to
your bank account and you use those
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online which protects your actual
debit card so that it's not spread all
over the Internet and one of the best
things about it is how their mobile app
and browser extensions for Chrome and
Firefox make it really easy to use let's
say for example that I'm signing up for
a David Pakman show membership in the
credit card number field I already see
the privacy com icon I just click it
choose which of my virtual credit cards
I want to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link